couldn't have a better evening and just a great
rivalry and a game that means so much to both
these teams temperature 3° at the opening face
off the Oilers 03 and one something has to get
But Here Comes McDavid in marks him in the net
able to hold that out plays in the neutral zone
looks like you're going on offense B f with
the good active stick now you're scrambling
to come back but an excellent effort of tan
Blake Coleman played in a couple of outdoor
games as a Collegiate player there's a chance
for D will back in and a rebound chance stopped
by markstrom and M japani will clear well Ryan
hus will be telling his D that that's twice now
turnovers in the neutral zone and gets that Top
Line created two good scoring chances and that's
just easy offense you can't afford to give that
McDavid D side the line good adjustment I can
have the first time coming back and maybe saving
a day and hasn't that been a recurring team for
cing so far this season nearly a steal here to
markstrom with a big save marstrom sharp in the
early going as he has been during this losing
streak there's a back in side of the net and
it'll be kolac moving the P rebounds SCS kolak
moved in and an adonara kid is the opening goal
of the Tim Hortons Heritage Classic following
up a couple of good shifts by the top line just
getting the puck to the net with a big traffic in
front inside position you have both Kane and Hyman
but as you mentioned coming back from the point he
kind of gets lost kulak rotated around gets in on
the back hand and here's Dylan du as dle returns
Leon dyle got him with H driving in McDavid in Fr
scores Zack hman after the Oilers kill the 513
Evander Kane after taking his penalty he came
out got a good chance now it's Drive CLE and at
the end of a long shift you got some tired bodies
out there for the Calgary Flames and what Leon
dry Sidle does best is distribute the puck just
Waits and allows hman to get by and get the puck
past the skate of weager and you can see markstrom
thinking he's got to reach out as far and off
hubero it out and they'll have to reorganize
It Center with time counting down on the first
penalty newon Hopkins getting set the return here
comes a chance scores McKenzie Winger tipped in
front and I think cry has his first of the season
with 1 second remaining in the newon Hopkins
penalty close call just making sure you're on side
then the pass across the scene and this is a shot
pass you know one of those with the traffic in
front said how many times they weren't able to get
the shot through it got blocked this time cadry's
got his body in position and he gets that one
in midair as Skinner tries to get it look at the
head up by weager he's looking at cadri the whole
time and there's the deflection and as you said
right at the last second and here's drle Center
nobody there back to dry settle again now McDavid
turns in the zone cross the goal M the D set of
blue Shar draws an answer from the Oilers and
it's [Applause] three1 Leon Dr settled a little
give and go here with Conor McDavid they keep it
down low and then look at sliding to his left with
bodies in front Zack Hyman's off to once I look at
all the red sweaters white and red sweaters in
front of markstrom I don't think he really even
sees this and it goes right over the shoulder as
Marr's trying to cry got Calgary on the board for
sh restores a two goal lead Oilers looking for
more in front marrom there to make that stop
saved one is again a turnover just inside the Zone
a two-on-one down low and marstrom slide 97 on it
lindol trying to stay with him rck wi right SLE
off the side of the and another great seam pass
by McDavid and he'll go to the neet FR AR got
a piece of [Applause] that now the puck squirts
loose and three to one these couple of early saves
there's just trying to slow down McDavid but that
pass through the seam quick little onetime just
the same wigs and they had the same old style
Oiler jerseys that they wore during that that
era as well how the heck did you stand on the
bench without a half honestly the bench was so
warm look at the guys right now too it's the same
the heaters on the bench were quite incredible
worked well so we didn't have to venture out too
far so we start the second period here with the
Oilers up by two a shot turned to Side by getner
a rebound and they do stay out FAL starts back and
McDavid in Flight with rle back to McDavid fr shot
on a rush Chance by marstrom 50 three-way passing
play there and he's getting the opportunity to
move up the lineup because of it AR getting set
to return weaker able to work his way through and
skino scores on the rebound as the penalty was
about to expire Calgary gets one back spying on
Conor McDavid playing the defensive role but this
is just taking matters into your own end look at
The Pedestrian D there for the Edmonton ERS as
eom gets standing still a swipe of the stick and
weager just jumps right through now you bring
a body to you on the back check and you forget
about the guy who just came on From the Bench is
Greer there's Coleman handing it off back centers
and Skinner across to make that stop Skinner all
of a sudden there's been more traffic around his
net PX in there and he does a nice job of sliding
across as it goes cross crease and Ron's just in
too tight there he's unable to get it up and over
yes Kyle Edmonson always comes through when they
host a big event and this has been no exception
and it could be quite a third period a one goal
game Legends come in very different packages don't
they yeah you saw that one picture with the towels
to dway man gak is such a big part here with
there's a go flection a ke tip in front I think
off the day day [Applause] shot when the battle
is won down low Hyman's fighting off his man it
gets cycled up and this is a such a smart play
by De har not a hard shot but you see the one
hopper is Kane tries at first it looks like to
jump out of the way but then it looks like he
knocks it that might even be da harn man what a
one hopper as look at the reaction of markstrom
he can't believe how high when that hits the ice
at the Gordy how hatrick in Minnesota here's a
chance the other way to shot both wi H swaps on it
it's picked up by du he'll feat it back to Gilbert
in some trouble there on his heels away goes
dry title penalty pending down low it goes for
f David CS work and gets it th title on the seam
pass that shot doesn't get to the net handed off
with the extra attacker out now for and right
lacrosse marks from the Stop and the whistle
sounds the Oilers with a two-goal lead there's a
centering pass to that du between the legs chance
kept alive at the line and now out empty net of
Amer K and that one will go to 91 and it's by to
Edon in the emotions of the outdoor the spectacle
of 60,000 and here with the play right at the line
the play was made by Derrik Ryan it just a good
job of winning that battle who will fall to two
six and one and a four game windless streak for
the Oilers has ended here at commonwell stadium